Ці лижники опинилися тут завдяки… сміттю.
Під цим лижним схилом знаходиться величезний сміттєспалювальний завод.
Він переробляє 400 тисяч тонн відходів на рік і перетворює їх на енергію та тепло для Копенгагена.
Він також переробляє 90% металевих відходів міста.
Дехто вважає, що такі сміттєспалювальні заводи можуть стати ключем до вирішення глобальної сміттєвої проблеми.
Але справді це так? Чи зрештою людству доведеться відмовитися від цієї ідеї?
Щороку в світі утворюється понад два мільярди тонн побутових відходів,
причому в країнах з високим рівнем життя їхні обсяги вищі відповідно до чисельності населення.
37 відсотків глобальних відходів опиняються на звалищах, забруднюючи ґрунтові води та виділяючи метан.
Менш ніж 20 відсотків світового сміття переробляється чи компостується.
У країнах, що розвиваються, вивезення сміття іноді просто не існує, і відходи найчастіше опиняються у річках -
це основне джерело пластику, що потрапляє до океанів.
Щоб позбутися якнайшвидше і якомога більших обсягів сміття, близько мільярда тонн відходів щорічно спалюється у відкритий спосіб.
Спалювання відкритим способом призводить до масштабних викидів так званого чорного вуглецю.
Це сажа, яка справді сильно впливає на глобальне потепління.
Зоє Ленкевич - одна із засновників організації Wasteaid і працює менеджеркою з утилізації відходів уже понад 20 років.
При цьому також утворюються діоксини та фурани, які, як відомо, викликають рак.
Все це потрапляє у повітря там, де люди спалюють відходи.
Спалювання сміття - серйозна проблема. Але якби був інший підхід до спалювання, з'явилася б низка переваг.
На допомогу приходить контрольоване спалювання сміття.
Сміттєспалювальні заводи вперше з'явилися там, де було важко організувати звалище: у Лондоні в 1874 році, потім у Нью-Йорку в 1885 році.
Сам процес спалювання сміття зменшує обсяг відходів на 90 відсотків.
Елла Штенґлер - керуюча директорка організації європейських операторів з переробки відходів на енергію.
І це виконує свого роду санітарні функції, тому що знищує забруднюючі речовини, що містяться у відходах.
Тепло, що виробляється, також може бути перетворене на енергію.
Це називається перетворенням відходів на енергію чи енергетичною утилізацією відходів.
У США, де багато місця та дешева енергія завдяки нафті, ця технологія була неконкурентоспроможною, тож багато заводів було закрито.
Але в ЄС будувалося дедалі більше сміттєспалювальних заводів.
Сьогодні вони забезпечують 18 мільйонів європейців електроенергією, а 15 мільйонів - теплом.
Енергетична утилізація відходів - звичайна справа для таких країн, як Данія та Нідерланди, які повністю відмовилися від захоронення відходів.
Екологічні організації вбачають потенціал у цій технології.
Це перехідний крок до більш циркулярної економіки, особливо в країнах, де немає великих площ та яким потрібно більше енергії.
Ось як працюють такі заводи. Сміття скидають у велику шахту - звідти воно надходить до печі.
Там підтримується дуже висока температура, і за лічені хвилини сміття згоряє.
Тепло від печей генерує пару, яка обертає турбіни. І вони виробляють електрику.
Пара також може бути використана для опалення.
10 відсотків сміття, яке не згоряє, називаються золошлаковими відходами, і з них можна витягти метали.
Залишок може бути використаний як будівельний матеріал.
Таким чином, така утилізація відходів зменшує обсяги сміття, виробляє енергію, а залишок також може бути перероблений.
Здавалося б, ідеальний вихід?
Але є кілька причин, через які у світі не так багато сміттєспалювальних заводів, що виробляють електроенергію.
Не кажучи вже про лижні траси на даху.
Одна з цих причин - летючий попіл - те, що вловлюється фільтрами.
Його потрібно утилізувати на полігонах для небезпечних відходів. Інша причина - висока вартість.
Якщо будується завод із переробки відходів в енергію, то він має бути оснащений найсучаснішими технологіями, які коштують дорого.
Вам потрібно навчити персонал правильно експлуатувати техніку, а органи влади - здійснювати належний контроль.
Навіть без лижних трас на даху будівництво заводу з переробки відходів в енергію може коштувати більше мільярда доларів США.
Без новітніх фільтрів та належного моніторингу, забруднення може досягти небезпечного рівня і мати наслідки для людей, які мешкають поблизу.
Крім того, такі заводи викидають багато вуглекислого газу: лише у ЄС це близько 52 мільйонів тонн на рік.
Це приблизно стільки, скільки виділять 430 тисяч автомобілів, кожен з яких проїде мільйон кілометрів.
Політики та промисловість ставлять сміттєспалювання за рівнем викидів в одну енергетичну групу
з відновлюваними джерелами енергії на кшталт вітру чи сонця, або навіть з атомною енергією.
Це Тетяна Луян. Вона очолює групу з питань екології в організації ClientEarth, а також працює над реалізацією директиви ЄС щодо циркулярної економіки.
Але якщо подивитися на рівень викидів парникових газів під час спалювання сміття, то вони досить близькі до викидів від спалювання вугілля та газу.
І ці показники дуже далекі від енергетики вітру, сонця чи ядерної енергії.
Дослідження, проведене на замовлення ClientEarth, показал
що контрольоване спалювання сміття спричиняє від 59 до 73 відсотків викидів, що відбуваються при спалюванні вугілля.
Таким чином там, де можливо правильно побудувати завод та ним керувати, контрольоване спалювання краще, ніж звалище.
Але це далеко не найчистіший варіант утилізації відходів незалежно від того, скільки енергії при цьому виробляється.
Погляньте на цю "піраміду ієрархії відходів". Не бійтеся, вона не така складна, як здається.
У самому низу піраміди знаходиться відкрите спалювання або захоронення відходів - найгірший із можливих способів звільнення від сміття.
Далі йде утилізація без повторного використання енергії, тобто захоронення або спалювання без вироблення енергії.
Потім на черзі перетворення відходів в енергію, це збірний термін для різних методів.
Далі - переробка відходів. Ще вище в ієрархії - повторне використання речей, яке теж часто називається переробкою.
І на самісінькому верху - профілактика та скорочення обсягів сміття.
Отже, наша планета ще дуже далеко від верхівки.
Заводи із переробки відходів в енергію відкриваються по всьому світу, наприклад, у Китаї, Індонезії та Індії.
Перший завод з переробки відходів на енергію в Африці щойно відкрився в Аддіс-Абебі в Ефіопії.
Але проблема виявилася складнішою, ніж просто відкрити заводи та спалити сміття.
Однією з причин є те, що склад відходів сильно варіюється залежно від країни.
Ви не можете взяти одну модель, яка працює в заможній країні, як форму для печива,
і чекати, що вона буде працювати в країні з низьким рівнем доходу, тому що це зовсім інший ринок.
В Індії побутові відходи приблизно на 50 відсотків складаються з органічних речовин, наприклад, із харчових відходів.
Для спалювання вони надто вологі. А через відсутність централізованого збору відходів сміття там часто змішується.
Я не думаю, що сортування сміття взагалі відбувається у більшості індійських міст. Тож це величезна проблема.
Прітпал Рандхава проводить дослідження в галузі управління відходами в Індії.
Відходи мають розподілятися. Небажані матеріали мають бути відокремлені від цих відходів.
І лише відходи з високою теплотворною здатністю мають бути спалені. Але насправді цього не відбувається.
Теплотворна здатність - це міра наскільки легко та чи інша речовина згоряє і виділяє тепло.
Сира нафта та змішані пластмаси мають теплотворну здатність близько 40 мегаджоулів на кілограм. Їжа - близько 16.
Без сортування сміття безліч харчових відходів потрапляє в печі, змушуючи заводи навіть додавати паливо.
Це робить все підприємство вкрай неефективним. Країни також повинні мати спеціальні полігони для зберігання небезпечних відходів.
Отже, якщо сміттєспалювання не є чарівним засобом для країн, що розвиваються, то які варіанти є ще?
Це зовсім нескладно - ідеально було б управління відходами на децентралізованому рівні.
І не тільки децентралізоване управління, а й диверсифіковане: спеціально пристосоване до довкілля та економіки району.
Біогаз, який одержують з органічних відходів, може бути джерелом палива. А з пластику можна робити будівельні матеріали.
У галузі управління відходами один стандарт не підходить для всіх.
І вам дійсно потрібно дивитися, що найкраще підходить для цього регіону.
Заводи з переробки відходів в енергію можуть існувати, але для цього необхідна злагоджена система сортування сміття
та сильний екологічний регулятор.
Але навіть якщо усе це є, країнам необхідно ретельно подумати, перш ніж будувати нові заводи.
Коли ви будуєте сміттєспалювальні заводи, ви робите величезні інвестиції та замикаєтеся в системі,
яку вам доведеться продовжувати годувати, годувати та годувати.
І це стримуючий фактор для переходу до справжньої циркулярної економіки.
Тому, перш ніж на планеті з'явиться ще більше сміттєспалювальних заводів, політикам слід розглянути можливість
фінансування більш далекоглядних методів утилізації відходів.
Наприклад, переробку, повторне використання і найголовніше - скорочення кількості відходів.